[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec soin
extra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous allez commenter l'actualité
de la semaine sur terre mais d'abord on
va parler de votre actualité à vous
alors eric de montgolfier bonsoir vous
êtes procureur pouvait me procurer quoi
au juste des filles nues à six noms de
l'injustice si ceux ci seront d'accord
alors fait des procureurs de la
république et vous avez été sous les
feux de l'actualité avec la sphère au mv
à ce pauvre bernard tapie s'est quand
même retrouvé au trou et puis plus
récemment non lieu de johnny hallyday
dans dans l' affaire de viol alors c'est
quand même bizarre avec de montgolfier
parce que quand vous bossez à
valenciennes dans latapie achète un
match quand vous bossez à nice johnny
hallyday s'est de violine fille est ce
que vous aviez un piège l'api paul
c'est parce que j'ai une espèce de
charme qui fait que j'attire ce type
d'affaires mais fait sans croire oui oui
il faut croire
alors mais pas attendu l'âge de la
retraite pour publier un livre qui
s'appelle le devoir de déplaire chez
michel lafon ah tiens j'ai un mètre de
vincent mcdoom qui vous a vue sur la
couverture avec une robe qui vous
demande elle est bien la robe que tu
portes tu l'as acheté ou saas et ses
macbook et mac do
alors c'est un livre passionnant
sur ce qui marche pas dans la justice
est un livre qui parle aussi c'est très
intéressant et passionnant des pressions
du pouvoir politique quand les élus ou
des who des stars sont mises en cause
ces voix compte et ou quoi michèle
bernier vous êtes sur la scène des
bouffes parisiens depuis le 22 septembre
dans dolores clairborne donc d'après
stephen king mise en scène de pascal
hoste harriet oies et demi
parce que j'avais déjà fait que michel
et mise en scène par marie pascale
osterrieth
arriverait pas qui en laisse penser que
c'est étonnant dans cette pièce michel
vraiment j'ai vu l'autre soir j'ai passé
une excellente soirée vraiment vous
monter une marche dans votre carrière
michel avec cette pièce j'ai
l'impression de porter tous les
désespoirs des femmes depuis toutes sont
des siècles décennies jeu j'ai
l'impression de voir ma grand mère voilà
des gens qui ont souffert qu'ils ont
rien dit qui ont tout supporter mais qui
ont fait des choses formidables par
amour pour les leurs proches et voilà je
me sens très très
habité par cette femme oui j'aime bien à
laurianne vous venez de publier panthéon
chez chez grasset donc un livre qui se
veut un roman moderne dans lequel vous
entremêlées votre autobiographie et une
hagiographie de françois mitterrand
alors quand on vous demande pourquoi
vous dites parce que finalement on a été
battus tous les deux lui dans les
élections et moi par mes parents je dis
qu'il de personnes les plus battu de
france dans les années 70 c'était
mitterrand et moi ouais mais j'ai le
droit de me comparer mitterrand parce
que quand elkabbach je vais demander en
94 mais qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
être présent la république il faut être
un requin qui leur etc mitterrand a
répondu pas plus de choses que pour être
directeur d'une salle de ping pong c'est
juste une question d'échelle
voilà alors bienvenue tous les soirs sur
le plateau de salut les terriens on va
commenter ensemble l'actualité de la
semaine et on va commencer c'est la
tradition dans cette émission par un
bonne nouvelle mauvaise nouvelle alors
zidane en couverture de voici avec nadia
bonnes nouvelles provinces nouvelle bah
ça dépend pour lequel des deux serait
bonne nouvelle pour elle mauvaise
nouvelle pour lui est une très bonne
nouvelle pour les choses entrevues
nouvelle de voir que zidane n'est pas un
martien mais un terrien parce qu'il ya
eu des coups de boule quand on les
emmerde et il est capable de tromper sa
femme est une bonne opération
vous en pensez quoi
je pense que sur ce sujet on a
suffisamment attenter à la vie privée
des uns et des autres pour que je ne
m'en mêle pas d'accord alors jack lang
rejoint ségolène royal
[Applaudissements]
bataille et fontaine menacé sur tf1 pour
audiences insuffisantes nouvelle
mauvaise nouvelle et je sais toujours
pas qui bataille et fontaine et mélange
les deux bouts [ __ ] de bataille c'est
la figure je crois non
gros alors après la victoire de reléguer
au nicaragua d'amérique latine après
chavez et lula continue à passer à
gauche bonne nouvelle mauvaise nouvelle
outre le brésil c'est une bonne nouvelle
ou lacan c'est un ouvrier il s'était
coupé un doigt quand il était machine
haut et c'est vous dire si une légende
chirac prêt à se présenter aux
présidentielles bonne nouvelle mauvaise
nouvelle pour s'excuser mitterrand
giscard il se présente une nouvelle fois
la présidentielle il ferait bien de
présenter ses excuses fallacieuses de
chirac
[Musique]
commence avec la justice on va profiter
de la présence d'eric de montgolfier sur
ce plateau le tombeur de bernard tapie
pour parler des hommes politiques et de
la justice ceux qui ont fait de la
prison peuvent-ils revenir par exemple
carignon un ex maire de grenoble ex
ministre de l'environnement et de la
communication accusé d'avoir détourné 10
9 millions de francs
condamné à 400 mille francs d'amendé
celle inverse qui aurait été plus
logique non enfin prendre c'est comme ça
condamné à cinq ans de prison il y en a
fait trois ans comme quoi il tient pas
finalement ses engagements d'un bref
carignon a du mal à revenir on va
regarder et on en parle après
il peut le savoir le mpc pas vraiment un
parti politique c'est plutôt une famille
regardez carignan tomber en 92 pour
corruption 29 mois de prison et bien la
famille ouvre toujours les bras les
militants ump de l'isère viennent de
désigner pour être leur prochain
candidat aux législatives sur cette
étape là je n'aurai pas le coeur ni la
motivation d'engager succombent à la
famille reconnaissante car carignon a
déjà défendu sa cause à l'assemblée
maire de grenoble députés il a même été
ministre de la communication son péché
mignon la communication tout le monde te
regarde quand tu poses avec des acteurs
et c'est la gloire du sort du tribunal
derrière des gendarmes tout le monde te
regarde encore mais cette fois ci c'est
la honte heureusement aux yeux de la
société tout va bien il a payé sa dette
il a retrouvé sa place non le problème
c'est la famille il paraît que le
nouveau chef a de gros soucis de
respectabilité et alain tu as même fait
29 mois cela car je n'ai pas l'habitude
de rencontrer des gens qui ont des coups
donnés par le justice
t'inquiète pas comme ça alain le
chapelet parlez pas de toi il parlait
d'imad lahoud le type soupçonné d'avoir
monté contre lui le complot clearstream
quoi c'est pas pareil tu es de la
famille
voilà alors eric est ce que vous
voteriez pour un homme qui a fait de la
prison non même s'il a payé sa dette à
la société maintenant s'il s'agit pas de
payer sa dette il s'agit de prétendre
représenter la nation dir il faut au
niveau de respectabilité
comme on vient de le dire
qui ne se discute pas ce qui me gêne
c'est plus longtemps je me suis demandé
à quoi je servais mais j'ai compris
maintenant à donner des labels pour les
élections
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
michel barnier pour pour un homme
politique qui a fait de la prison certes
on se dit toujours que c'est quand même
elle qui bat sa femme ou quoi ben ce
jour il dit dont je le ferai plus pire
commence donc on se dit qu'à un moment
elle aussi en plus on le donne desquels
l'âme la mara qui nous qui nous dirigent
car un grand fair donc même si à un
moment il ya dix l'a fait de la taule et
qu'il a dit je le ferai plus la
confiance vont s'isoler d'amis confiance
à moi ça me posera aucun problème parce
que d'abord l'être humain est
perfectible et on a le droit d'avoir une
deuxième chance dans la vie c'est la
première chose et je trouve que le fait
d'avoir payé sa dette c'est quand même
pas rien et tout le monde est
perfectible on peut changer et la
deuxième chose c'est que je pars du
principe que tous les hommes politiques
sont relativement mal honnête et que lui
il a eu des exigences de se faire pendre
super comme vous je pense pas qu'ils
suffisent comme on dit avoir payé sa
dette pour pouvoir ensuite prétendre aux
suffrages des électeurs non pays sa
dette c'est aussi régler ce que l'on
doit imaginer un magistrat qui
commettrait un crime et il passe en
prison puis après il revient et juger
les autres parce qu'il ment
la prison lui apprendre peut-être des
choses qu'ils n'auraient pas comprise si
les tests et vous suggérons magistrats
d'être d'abord des criminels ou de dés
maintenant pour préserver les
obligations de le devenir mais si par
exemple par hasard il veut raison on
peut dire et des goudes social où vous
nous souhaiter de l'expérience non non
je dis seulement que l'expérience de la
prison peut changer les êtres humains
et les faire évoluer quoi donc pas
forcément les faire régresser vous savez
que c'est un c'est une véritable utopie
et que moi je rêve justement quand je
peux mettre quelqu'un en prison qu'ils
en sortent le meilleur faudrait-il
encore que les conditions carcérales on
est d'accord je veux dire un truc
carignon oka réunion que celui qui n'a
jamais détourné 19 millions de francs
lui jette la première pierre
bien alors il est le devoir de déplaire
c'est michel lafon alors ça fait 13 ans
qu'on vous demande d'écrire ce ce
bouquin vous l'avez fait à vous l'avez
fait pour 80000 euros d'avaloirs quand
même oui bien bien bien merci pour les
prisons sont le sait bien meilleur
confort
vous ai
fait la charité avec votre argent
laissez moi alors vous racontez vos
trente ans d'expérience et surtout
comment magistrat résistent aux
pressions enfants tous les cars qui vous
concernent d'abord dans la sphère au mba
mitterrand le président de la république
de l'époque donc a défendu publiquement
bernard tapie dans son interview du 14
juillet 1993 oui c'est juste le
président de la république
constitutionnellement garant de
l'indépendance de la magistrature a pris
position dans une affaire un cours en
nous expliquant comment il fallait
comprendre le dossier ouais
et la réaction du magistrat dans ces cas
là qu'est ce qu'il a dit ouais
alors bernard tapie je les appelais
parce que je savais que vous étiez là
aujourd'hui donc j'appelle bernard
ardura bon alors tu dis je suis dit
qu'est ce que tu penses de montgolfier
dit il ya la morale et le droit
montgolfier n'y fait pas respecter le
droit il applique la morale sa morale et
au nom de sa morale il est prêt à se
permettre n'importe où moi j'ai
l'impression de faire un tapis applique
son droit et qu'on ôte son droit il fait
n'a pas
vous n'arrivez pas oublier vos
convictions personnelles quoi il dit que
finalement c'est montgolfier c'est pas
la république bernard tapie a sûrement
l'état de qualité mais avant qu'ils ne
puissent devenir juge des juges qui
pourra s'écouler un peu de temps
d'accord
il ya eu des pressions de mitterrand à
l'époque de tapis bien aussi bernadette
chirac à l'époque où donc à l'idée était
accusé par cette fille marie christine
vos de viol bernadette chirac a dit
c'est incroyable ça quand même je vis
dans votre bouquin c'est surréaliste
ceux qui s'en prendraient à johnny le
paierait les français n'aiment pas ça ce
qui m'a gêné c'est que là où elle est
elle devrait faire preuve d'une réserve
un peu plus grand besoin utile mais là
aussi qu'est ce qu'elle a dit ouais
alors la solution vous dit effectivement
c'est quand même la presse malgré ses
approximations et vous dit que vous avez
été tenté
très souvent de tout balancer au canard
enchaîné c'est la meilleure façon de se
protéger maintenant non pas de se
protéger mais de faire sortir un certain
nombre de dossiers qui restent dans
l'ombre il s'agit pas de se protéger
c'était pas une constante et c'est vrai
que je connais nombre de dossiers qui
n'ont ne sont pas allés devant les juges
parce que ce qui était en cause étaient
trop puissants pour que quelques uns
apprennent la décision contre eux et et
je trouve ça bien dommage parce que je
crois à la justice et à l'égalité ouais
eric de montgolfier le devoir de
déplaire c'est chez michel lafon on y
reviendra avant la pub on va se faire un
petit top five les cinq signes qui vous
font dire que vous êtes mal parti dans
un procès alors votre avocat comment sa
plaidoirie en dix ans
disait à l'imac ville
vous avez demandé au procureur s'il
était nue sous sa robe
votre avocat vous a demandé discrètement
si le juge c'est bien celui qui a le
petit marteau
votre avocat parce le vendredi soir si
julien courbet
vous avez répondu je ne peux pas vous le
dire c'est un secret au procureur
[Musique]
on
se retrouve après la ville pour la suite
de celle là
m
oh
[Musique]
rien
on va continuer à passer en revue
ensemble l'actualité de la semaine la
ville était rien et on va parler de
nicolas hulot alors selon les sondages
43% des français et 99% des ours des
pyrénées souhaite qu'il se présente aux
présidentielles ça à faire beaucoup de
nicolas beaucoup de nicolas aux
présidentielles on regarde et on en
parle après
si un présentateur vedette de tf1
devrait devenir président de la
république
vous préféreriez que ce soit bataille où
que ce soit fontaine vous voteriez
plutôt pour nikos aliagas ou pour
benjamin castaldi pour l'instant aucun
cela n'est candidat mais leur confrère
nicolas hulot lui pourrait bien se
présenter voilà des années qu'il nous
répète il faut le sauver la planète les
hommes politiques eux n'ont rien contre
l'idée de sauver la planète ce qu'ils
veulent avant tout c'est que nicolas
hulot ne se présentent pas aux
présidentielles alors ils veulent lui
faire plaisir hulot réclament un vice
premier ministre chargé de l'écologie
fabius lui offre le poste hulot réclame
une taxe sur le gaz carbonique sarkozy
veut des taxes écologiques seule
ségolène royal trouve la candidature de
hulot inutile c'est vrai que les
vedettes qu'on préfère en politique
c'est celle qui sont toujours d'accord
avec vous pas vrai docteur voilà l'art
eric une oppression république j'ai un
peu tendance à considérer que la
politique reste une chose sérieuse
surtout dans la fonction présidentielle
encore que mais bon j'aimerais mieux ne
pas me perdre dans
dans la poussière du désert
qu'est ce qu'on pense de lui le
président toi président peut-être pas
mais en tout cas ça serait bien qu'on me
donne une place une vraie place si al
gore à l'envers algues ont elles été
malheureux à la présidentielle d'abord
il s'occupait de la planète après hulot
ici il s'occupe la planète d'abord il
sera malheureux présidentielle apparaît
alors
alors c'est vrai quand même que cette
prise de conscience écologique c'est pas
seulement un mouvement d'opinion c'est
aussi un phénomène moral qu'il y ait une
espèce de retour du sacré du spiritueux
pour les quelques uns qui aurait connu
les années
68 70
il y avait charrié dos et dans l'hebdo
il y avait un grand écologiste qui
s'appelait pierre fournier pape avait
lancé un journal qui s'appelait la
gueule ouverte ce qui était déjà avec
reiser l'énergie solaire et ses 50 ans
lens 0 1 gb ça fait 30 ans que ces gens
avec la leur stylo leur énergie leur
intelligence ont essayé de donner des
signaux d'alarmé important et c'est de
ces gens là ont été méprisés par les
médias les politiques on les prenait
pour des rigolos alors maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça commence à être
un peu tard déjà brad we
[Applaudissements]
c'est le culte d'environnement qu'une
chose importante est le culte de la
nature la mythologie allemand des nazis
repose sur la silver la forêt quoi donc
oui à l'environnement et à sa sauvegarde
et non au culte absolu de la nature quoi
je me méfie du culte de la nature non
mais c'est vrai que nature qui me fait
peur le culte de la nature et le vix
thèmes sont sur des êtres humains qu'un
peu de pollution que des animaux des
arbres si oui alors c'est sûr que les
extraterrestres doivent rien comprendre
à ce qui se passe sur notre planète on
va regarder les cinq questions que les
extraterrestres se poserait si débarquer
sur terre cette semaine
mais pourquoi vous congelez beau bébé
vous les mangez plus tard 6 à
thierry ardisson pour des savoir si les
terres yens ressembla montgolfier ou
anggun
c'est quoi cette météo de merde il est
où jacques villeret on ne te voit lui
dira ce connard
non sans rire votre chef c'est bush
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nos jeunes
pour les abonnés en parler maintenant de
la condamnation à mort de saddam hussein
alors condamné à mort pour 148
villageois chiites c'est un peu décevant
quand même pour un dictateur de cette
envergure moi je trouve
serait pas été plus cruel de lui raser
la moustache comme carignon comme karim
vous l'exécutez avec les fameuses armes
de destruction massive qui l'avait pas
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble et on
en parle après
pouvoir au peuple pour voir au vrai
gouvernement irakien je ne reconnais pas
votre pouvoir taisez vous
[Musique]
on a tous vu assez de films américains
pour savoir que le méchant meurt
toujours à la fin saddam hussein a bien
sûr été jugé par un tribunal irakien et
indépendant mais comme par hasard sa
condamnation à mort n'a surpris personne
il était jugé pour avoir fait fusiller
143 villageois mais ce n'était qu'une
infime proportion de ces crimes alors
oui si le méchant doit absolument mourir
à la fin celui là mérite de mourir mais
c'est justement ça la question est ce
que le méchant mérite de mourir du point
de vue du shérif ça ne fait aucun doute
sa dame doit être pendu haut et court
sur le vieux continent on laisse la
peine de mort aux barbares tout le monde
est contre même l'adjoint du sheriff
tony blair finalement le seul qui soit
d'accord avec le shérif c'est le nouveau
super méchant ahmadinejad le président
iranien se félicite de la condamnation à
mort de saddam hussein qui avaient
envahi son pays en 79 mais vous vous
trouvez pas ça bizarre que le shérif
soit d'accord avec le nouveau super
méchant voilà donc saddam hussein était
un criminel faut-il en faire un martyr
eric de montgolfier tout ça n'a rien à
voir avec la justice je dois le préciser
lorsque la politique se fait juge chaput
de la justice je suis pas favorable à la
peine de mort pourquoi le serais-je pour
saddam hussein crois que dès lors que la
victime se fait bourreau elle perd sa
légitimité de victimes c est pareil
c'est dommage c'est que les gens qui
sont contre la peine de mort pour saddam
hussein ne soit pas contre la peine de
mort pour les irakiens qui meurent tous
les jours parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
plus je pense que la vie de chaque être
humain appartient à l'être humain en
question mais que la mort de chaque être
humain appartient à tout le monde donc
on peut être responsable de sa vie mais
c'est l'humanité tout entière qui est
responsable de la mort de quelqu'un je
qu'on leur amène demain comme celle de
sa 2ème salle de s'amuser est ce que si
on commence à avoir des cas particuliers
dans la peine de mort on s'en sort plus
on ait une justice au cas par cas sur le
sujet et sur certains principes il faut
être universel notamment la mort alors
ils avaient de tessier avait prévu la
condamnation à mort de sa belle scène
vous savez ça déconne
sur toi
[Musique]
e
alors cette semaine donc le journal
voici a fait sa une sur une rumeur la
rumeur d'une histoire entre zinedine
zidane et la chanteuse nadia
c'est ridicule c'est c'est ridicule
comme s'ils pouvaient pas d'amitié entre
entre un homme et une fille bien gaulée
je trouve ça vraiment là alors zidane en
voici pourquoi pas kate moss dans
l'équipe puisqu'on aura tout vu donc il
y a un an kate moss perdez tous ses
contrats publicitaires pour une photo où
elle prenait de la coke et aujourd'hui
elle est de retour au top c'est dommage
parce qu'elle va avoir de nouveau les
moyens d'en acheter c'est un peu dommage
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble on en
parle après
vous n'avez pas l'impression en
regardant la télé que parfois on se fout
un peu de votre gueule on vous dit blanc
un jour noir de lendemain tout ça avec
la même conviction prenons l'exemple de
kate moss il a peu de temps sa carrière
la paix soit disant fichu table ville
l'avait montré en train de prendre de la
coke tu pars d'une histoire mais même
les enfants de 3 ans à que les lapins
moche des carottes que les ours mangent
du miel que les mêmes quelle table de la
coke
pourtant ce faux scoop a été relayée
dans le monde entier comme une nouvelle
très importante et devant tendre affût
des marques de luxe ont même dû rompre
leur contrat avec kate moss aux
dernières nouvelles kate était donc dans
une grosse galère et puis soudain voilà
de cette semaine elle est élue mannequin
de l'année en grande-bretagne et la
voilà à nouveau dock bref on vous parle
de kate moss en noir ou de kate moss en
blanc on vous parle toujours la même
chose de kate moss du strass des
paillettes du showbiz de l'habitat s'il
est sans effort sinon on signale en
espagne cette semaine une conférence de
presse de femmes colombiennes victimes
de la violence des narcotrafiquants mais
elles sont carrément moins sexy kate
moss alors le vice président colombien
santos a critiqué évidemment cette
glorification de la cocaïne il devrait
pas parce que kate moss représente quand
même la moitié des revenus du pays là
bas cette glorification de la cocaïne ça
vous choque autant que le vice-président
colombien eric de montgolfier je trouve
ça absurde de laisser croire les jeunes
gens qu'il n'y a pas de mal à prendre de
la drogue même du cannabis même du cac
pourtant la société évolue voyez
maintenant tout le monde fut malgré tout
le monde peut-être mais pas moi
mais
par rapport aux histoires de kate moss
de ce que j'ai entendu dans les
histoires de mannequins etc c'est que le
problème qu'elles ont c'est d'être
d'aider des portemanteaux maigre maigre
mec comme des les trucs là les
chandeliers là et que c'est vrai que la
cocaïne est un coupe faim extraordinaire
sauf que je préfère être dépendante du
mythe et la queue de la cocaïne
et bomba kate moss tournée celle s'en
sort mais il a plein à côté qui s'en
seraient pas comme ça et sur kate - si
ça continue on l'appelle raquette moche
dans quelques années bassett façon très
très moche même parce que généralement
je vous le dis mesdames les maigres en
vieillissant spa télé ne fait qu' elle
soit devenu comme ça une icône alors
qu'elle est officiellement cocaïnomane
ça démontre une certaine décadence non
ça démontre que c'est le vrai people
dans l'histoire c'est la coke elle même
ouais c'est pas là les people qui
prennent de la coke c'est la coupe qui
devenu vraiment l'héroïne selon les mots
du milieu qui pose que je reviens aux
jeunes téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent et même aux vieux de liart
c'est que la cocaïne c'est très très
mauvais parce que cette détruisent la
myéline labeling c'est ce qui entoure
les neurones c'est une substance grasse
qui entoure les neurones et donc au bout
d'un moment dans les neurones qui se
touchent comme des fils électriques sans
sans matières plastiques autour quoi
voilà donc je tenais à le dire non
prenez pas voilà fabien pas bien
[Applaudissements]
savoir si quand on achète de la drogue
moi c'est un peu ce que j'ai dis 'ah 12e
à fille par exemple c'est que la drogue
la limite pourquoi ça marche parce que
sur le moment c'est vachement bien ouais
on est d'accord il ya ce revers ne
prendrai pas bon c'est que le problème
c'est que ça nourrit tout un tas de
salopards 1 derrière ça c'est à dire des
proxénètes des assassins et procureurs
et procureurs
[Applaudissements]
alors eric de montgolfier dans le devoir
de déplaire chez michel lafon donc vous
raconter la sphère marie-christine vaud
qui affirmait avoir été violée par
johnny hallyday sur le pont d'un bateau
du port de cannes alors vous avez laissé
tomber la fermer votre intime conviction
c'est quoi sur cette affaire devant je
n'ai pas laissé tomber la sphère j'ai
fait un constat un moment donné quand le
dossier n'a été communiqué qu'il n'y
avait pas de charges suffisantes
le problème de ce dossier c'est que on
n'arrive pas dans ce pays à faire
admettre que devant la justice il ne
peut pas y avoir privilèges et c'est la
seule chose que l'on peut affirmer à
travers ce dossier j'ai détesté le fait
autres madame chirac qu'un certain
nombre de journalistes et fait des
papiers qui me paraissaient des papilles
orienté 1 prenez partir je ne parlais
pas de prendre parti ce serait
aujourd'hui tout le monde prendre parti
sur les affaires judiciaires
les ministres pour tout le monde et ils
prennent tous dé déminer la mort et pour
nous expliquer que la justice c'est
quelque chose de précieux ballons et ils
lagache en permanence alors bernard
tapie vous soupçonne en fait de vous
occuper des affaires depuis paul pour
vous faire mousser
oui bon je comprends que bernard tapie
pense ça parce qu'il a passé toute sa
vie à se faire mousser
j'imagine que son problème c'est simple
et beaucoup de gens qui nous prête des
sentiments assez bas mais en fait ces
sentiments ne sont jamais que les leurs
alors je vais leur s alors kate moss est
sans doute un peu accro à la coke on va
voir à quoi vous êtes accro vous on va
faire une interview accro à quelle
émission de télé avez vous été accro
eric bon je pense que c'est le journal
télévisé abbas est gentil pour les
autres
ce sera un kwassa luthérien vous allez
voir pourrez plus vous en place et et
toi quelle émission de télé toutes les
séries américaines on voit la toile
polar j'adore accro à fond fbi les
experts tous chu folle le manège
enchanté seinfeld et tout le monde en
parle
dialogue
[Applaudissements]
et quels vêtements avez vous déjà été
accro eric ce que je porte et je porte
depuis 60 ans quasiment
mais on a le droit d'être un gars aussi
vous savez c'est très classique c'est
vouloir c'est bien le people ringard
c'est
ça va
et toi quels vêtements tu avais déjà été
accro à ces dons mais quand je veux pas
qu'ils passent
les best quand je me ramasse et oui très
bien merci ah qu'est l'alcool avez vous
déjà été accro
on la suze la suze
rien que lui ment sortir ça me sert
devient monsieur très haut la main sur
abba génération
toi t'as quoi quoi moi je suis né dans
le champagne avec papa donc voilà donc
l'accord en art comme chirac 1 comme s'y
attendent le seul point commun ces
règles peut faire des toits mitterrand à
quelle drogue et vous déjà été accro le
café le café bien vu c'est qu'on
commence par le café peut se terminer
que l'héroïne
[Applaudissements]
telle drogue
je dirais dépensière ouais ma carte
bleue des toits le sexe le sexe
avec l'ensemble avec suse à la carte
bleu mc bon sens l'entraîneur aussi
bonne soit elle a besoin
[Musique]
ado
nokia bravo note jean
michel2 telle affiche donc le dollar est
claire barlow du parisien mise en scène
par marie pascale osterrieth absolument
et vous êtes michel étonnante emparé du
personnage alors c'est une femme qui
raconte sa vie on pourrait l'accuser de
la mort de deux personnes son mari et sa
patronne en fait la pièce déroule sans
arrêt entre le présent et le passé ce
que je me valent de l'or et se promène
dans son passé rejoue les scènes on
retrouve son mari sa fille sa patronne
et ses ballons la scénographie est
excellent vin c'est magnifique et très
fier de la mise en scène de marie
pascale et puis du travail de jacques
oursins et laurent castaing qui ont fait
la lumière les décors alors c'est une
pièce qui est tiré de stephen king et
qui aborde les grands thèmes de
l'actualité la violence familiale ça ne
vous surprendra pas l'alcoolisme la
pédophilie l'euthanasie c'est très en
plus ses actuels mélasse très moderne
j'aime la popularité et la simplicité de
ces gens donc ils se protègent ils
s'excusent ils savent pas comment se
dépatouiller avec tout ça parce que ce
sont des problèmes dont ils ont pas
entendu parler ils ont pas été à l'école
pour savoir la psychologie le 6 le là
donc ils se démerdent comme ils peuvent
et dolores claiborne c'est une femme qui
a un moment décide d'être une [ __ ]
pour survivre et c'est ce que je trouve
formidable et quand on entend toutes les
histoires assez triste décès enfants on
retrouve mort et c'est la petite jeune
fille avec son petit bébé tout ça je
pense qu'à un moment il ya des femmes
qui ne savent plus quoi faire quinon qui
ne sont pas qu'ils n'ont pas été assez
aimée assez à qui on n'a pas donné assez
alors qu'à un moment elle puisse donner
elle même et je crois qu'elles ont tout
d'un coup hélas le dernier recours c'est
voilà jeu
et je sais pas comment faire mais je
vais tuer je vais faire autrement je
sais pas quoi faire voilà c'est c'est
c'est quelque chose de très très humain
cette pièce elle est d'une humanité
absolue de vêtements parce que parce
qu'il ya tout ça dedans il ya de ce
sentiment réel 2 qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans sa vie quand on est une femme de
ménage condamner quelqu'un de simple
qu'on habite dans une île un peu paumé
et qu'on a rien d'autre que soi comme
référence et que ses propres sentiments
voilà foyer d'avoir un sept pièces à moi
je les ai vus j'ai passé une soirée
excellente vraiment je vous conseille à
tous d'aller la voir c'est vraiment une
très bonne caisse ça m'a fait très
plaisir de voir ça
[Musique]
jacques à estevan bio
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est un bon soir marie alors le
csam interdit de dire quel est le livre
de stéphane guillon ou stéphane guillon
est sur scène ont plus que fait stéphane
guillon ce soir avec la division pharma
on n'a pas
donc on ne dit pas mais vous pouvez dire
ce que vous avez préparé non juste avant
de commencer je voulais dire à eric de
montgolfier que je vous en veux un peu
voilà parce que depuis que vous avez mis
bernard tapie en prison maintenant il
fait l'acteur et c'est beaucoup plus
pénible pour tout le monde
commence par une bonne nouvelle cécilia
sarkozy regarde l'émission thierry rey
la semaine dernière je m'interrogeais
sur la sexualité du petit nicolas et
bien dès le lendemain cécilia me
répondait dans libération sarkozy c'est
le pied
alors nouveau test nicolas en at il une
grosse peut-être une réponse demain est
ce que notre c'est important quand même
vie sociale les sans-papiers s'installe
chez ni [ __ ] ni soumises moi si j'étais
sans papiers ce qui n'est déjà pas très
rigolo quitte à m'installer quelque part
je choisirai une [ __ ] soumises
aéroports
aéroports nouvelles restrictions
draconiennes tous les liquides sont
interdits en cabine résultats steevy ne
pourra plus prendre l'avion avec martha
barrière qui est quand même très très
liquide
politique
politique dans vsd le pen se réfère à
clemenceau c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de
points communs entre le pen et le porte
avions ce sont deux vieux rafiot l'un à
plus de radars l'autre est borgne en 99
le clemenceau perd son hélice le pen sa
prostate turbines au point mort est à
sanitaire détestable 1 et bourré
d'amiante l'autre et xénophobe les deux
sont bretons malheureusement les
mouettes ne chie que sur le clémenceau
attention si l'un a été désarmé l'eau
peut encore frapper le coulé très vite
toujours dans vsd le journal analyse la
gestuelle des politiques moi j'ai vu des
titres de films laurent fabius dans
haïti et les aimer aux
le pen affreux sales et méchants
philippe de villiers choix très très
choquant jacques chirac à bout de
souffle françois hollande ma femme
s'appelle reviens
fait-divers encore deux bébés en moins
cette semaine un noyé façon villemin un
congelés façon courjault il n'y a pas
que la star ac pour devenir connus pour
endiguer cette tendance le journal le
parisien vous propose pour 12 euros une
fausse une avec la photo de votre petit
une façon d'épater vos potes sans
trucider bébé
attendez après c'est pire
à ce propos la mère du petit david a
tenté de se suicider au liquide
vaisselle elle c'est raté bah oui si
vous avalez du liquide vaisselle faut
courir et boire en même temps faut que
ça mousse sinon ça marche pas
[Musique]
première sortie publique d'isabelle
dinoire la greffée du visage elle boit
elle fume elle rigole bientôt la reprise
d'une vie sexuelle mais là la famille du
donneur s'inquiète c'est quand même la
bouche de notre fille trop tard donner
c'est donner
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mondialisation la société ikea emploie
des travailleurs asiatiques payer 0 90
centimes d'euro la journée leur slogan
c'est ikea et la hica est là pour les
[ __ ] la deuxième partie du slogan est
moins connu
attendez thirsk on est en train de me
dire que l'audience de l'émission
s'effrite légèrement donc je vais poser
une question ou non je posais une
question à michel bernier pour que
l'audit a slave trade center était
michel je voudrais tordent le cou à la
rumeur il paraît que vous avez une
aventure avec zinedine zidane
c'est bon l'audience reprend c'est bon
on va sauver l'émission j'aimerais
[Rires]
télévision on commence par une devinette
sur la table de nuit de pascal sevran il
ya quelque chose qui fait mal au cul à
votre avis thierry qu'est ce que c'est
je ne peux pas maintenant eh bien il le
dit lui même dans la presse j'ai mis la
photo de sarkozy à côté de celle
d'imiter ans c'est vrai que ça fait mal
au cul
on se demandait comment olga la chienne
de michel drucker pouvait endurer chaque
semaine l'enregistrement de vivement
dimanche notamment un spécial chez la
pauvre bête eh bien on a la réponse que
les chiens souffrent aussi d' alzheimer
pour elle à chaque fois c'est son
premier vivement dimanche
pis paul il ya quinze jours madonna
adopté david un petit malawi et bien
cette semaine lollobrigida 79 ans adopte
xavier rigo un jeune avocat de 34 ans
son cadet il est propre il mange tout
seul et surtout il est formé
presse on termine par un voici
particulièrement immonde cette semaine
le journal inaugure une nouvelle
rubrique la torture morale la recette
prenez jacques martin qui est paralysé
dans un établissement médicalisé puis
achevé le en publiant des photos de sa
femme batifolant avec un jeune homme
fringant dans le même temps voici offre
une cafetière au lecteur qui s'abonnent
pour les filtres utiliser du papier cure
je tripe de scouts où c'est encore mieux
le journal lui même voilà
merci merci ca
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà on se retrouve à
sa fille
parti de salut les terriens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
wiley
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
là
le faire ensemble ce dernier
dernier sujet les qualités que le
commenteront cette semaine avec nos
invités le prix goncourt attribué après
celui de l'académie française à
johnattan little pour les bienveillantes
c'est du jamais vu un premier roman de
900 pages écrit en français par un
américain à peine 40 ans dont on ne
savait rien avant l'été qui s'est
installé en tête des ventes et a raflé
deux prix majeurs mais fallait-il
l'écrire ce bouquin on regarde on en
parle après
nous autres français ils ont en moyenne
moins de deux livres par an alors autant
vous dire qu'on s'en fout complètement
des écrivains pourtant chaque année
miracle grâce aux prix goncourt tous les
cameramans de paris vont se marcher sur
les pieds pour filmer un simple écriteau
sauf que cette année il n'y avait
personne à filmer dans les jt il faudra
donc se contenter d'un pauvre polaroïd
chinatown little 38 ans qui a déjà vendu
250 mille exemplaires des bienveillantes
est resté chez lui à barcelone du coup
sur place eh ben les cameramans fils
beigbeder et nous
[Musique]
little lui ne se montre pas car ils
voudraient qu'on parle de son livre et
pas de lui les bienveillantes c'est le
récit à la première personne d'un nazi
qui raconte sa vie sans remords sur 900
pages peut-on adopter un tel point de
vue peut-on regarder ces images
d'archivés n'éprouvant sincèrement la
satisfaction du travail bien fait c'est
pourtant le point de vue du personnage
de little vous vous direz que vous
n'avez rien en commun avec lui vous vous
direz que c'est un monstre et pourtant
c'est un être humain et salif et au bout
du compte a sacré point commun avec le
lecteur voilà alors le pitch bas tout le
monde le connaît c'est l'extermination
des juifs d'europe racontée par un ss à
la première personne un être cultivé
intelligent c'est assez troublant alors
utile morale de faire parler un nazi est
il moral de mettre la shoah en fiction
eric oui il me semble que ça fait partie
de l'histoire du monde je crois que ce
sont des événements terribles qui ont
marqué les uns et les autres pourquoi ne
pas essayer de comprendre au tour ' si
jamais tu mon métier même le le plus
grand criminel de la terre quand je me
croise et je ne poursuis je dois essayer
de comprendre qu'on patients n'ont pas
compassion c'est même pas de la curieuse
t c'est juste pour être plus intelligent
le problème que pose ce livre c'est
qu'ils rajoutent de la confusion à un
sujet c'est à dire que c'est pas du tout
un livre qui permet d'éclairer la shoah
c'est un livre qui rajoute de la
confusion qui rajoute du flou c'est un
écran de fumée et on comprend encore
moins ce que c'est quand on lit un petit
exemple on dit ah oui c'est un être
humain comme les autres voilà ce que
c'est d'être à la fois nazi est un mec
normal et c'est un problème sur la
banalité du mal c'est le plus gros
contre sens qu'on puisse faire sur ce
livre parce que justement little rate
complètement la chose parce que sont
l'asie qui est censé être comme tout le
monde il est comme personne c'est dire
qu'il est à la fois homosexuels
pédophiles il comme et l'ins institut
son père sa mère son meilleur ami il est
alcoolique et en plus il est nazi donc
déjà on n'est pas dans la banalité du
mal on est dans l'exception du mal déjà
première chose d'eux et une parka
nullarde est dans ce livre qu'il faut
souligner c'est à dire que dans tout le
livre mais personne ne la lui je crois
lire c'est ça le problème il ya une part
d' écran de fumée on comprend un peu
moins la shoah que lorsqu'on avait des
cours à sciences po si on se pose
j'avais un cours sur la shoah le
troisième reich et on avait les bases
erronées chronique on étudie les livres
les gan kershaw sur hitler de raul
hilberg sur la destruction des juifs
d'europe on avait des choses très clair
sur les écoles historiques le livre de
lire une telle fait des figures de style
sur le sujet alors que les bases ne sont
même pas développé et par ailleurs je
termine sur le style pour moi c'est un
livre qui parle de la période de 1940
écrit dans un style de 1922 quoi c'est à
dire que c'est un style qui est
antérieur au sujet dont il parle or les
grandes persécutions les grande
déflagration mondiale et les grands
événements du xxème siècle servent aussi
à faire évoluer l'art c'est ne peut pas
écrire en 2006 comme on écrivait avant
que la choix existe donc de la merde
sans nom ne pas lire ce livre un livre
confus dangereux prétentieux et inutile
de
lui
panthéon de yann moix publié chez
grasset les messieurs alors yann
vous raconter dans votre livre panthéon
que vos parents vous battez et que
finalement pour vous il était un peu la
gestapo qui vous déportés la nuit dans
la forêt d'orléans quand vous aviez été
pas gentil à la maison et et votre père
vous rentrez dedans dit vous comme un
comme un jean moulin alors après little
c'est pas un peu dérisoire ça de se
comparer à un juif
non pas du tout on peut toujours être
juif sans l'être dire que quand vous
avez tout le monde à dos des juifs quand
quelqu'un vous est détesté par un
maximum de gens vous vous sentez un juif
c'est tout mais alors jeté
extraordinaire dans le bouquin de yann
c'est que ses parents le bad bon ça
c'est arrivé avant distincts pink floyd
la beat generation chez moi c'était ça
sert que la première génération de
d'enfants battus par des gens tout et
jefferson airplane toute la journée ça
si c'est très étrange tu vois c'est
comment battu par un lecteur de charlie
hebdo c'est ce que disait on n'attend
pas ton père tu n'as pas fait pas au
moins à michel jamais jamais je ne sais
même pas ce que ça veut dire jamais
alors pour survivre à la violence de vos
parents vous vous construisez une sorte
de panthéon spécial un ps ou mitterrand
trône en maître élan vous défendez
mitterrand dans ce qu'il a de moins
défendables quand il était un jeune
étudiant d'extrême droite au quartier
latin dans les années 30 et qui criait
la france aux français les métèques
dehors donc c'est marrant de le mettre
dans votre panthéon alors qu'en fait
vous dites des choses terribles sur lui
en fait pour régler le problème
définitivement jeudi que oui mitterrand
a été d'une certaine manière d'extrême
droite et oui d'une certaine manière il
était fasciste et pour
les c'est là que les écrivains sont plus
forts que les biographes et journalistes
qu'on peut se permettre des figures de
style est une des figures de style que
je m'autorise d'un livre c'est de faire
parler à la première personne le
fascisme de françois mitterrand il
bonjour les amis je suis le fascisme
français mitterrand et je peux vous dire
que c'était un très mauvais élève il
était venu l'an fachiste il a essayé
j'ai cru qu'ils allaient exterminer ses
amis juifs machin il n'a jamais insulté
jack lang devant moi machin il était nul
à marcel voilà un col ariane n'ai pas eu
de prix cette année un jury sur les de
l'interallié encore mouais on va faire
le pré moix 2006 alors le bouquin qui
aurait mérité le goncourt alors voyage
au bout de la nuit de céline et cette
année cette année circulent tant qu'ils
ne donneront pas voyage ou bleu nuit je
ne pourrais pas considérer les schémas
zlin qu'il a eue entre
le bouc à qui vous a filé des boutons
les bienveillantes de jonathan littell
parce que le nazisme littéraire literary
zay à ce point me donne des boutons le
bouquin qui nous a endormis les
bienveillantes johnattan little citée
comme 900 pages le bouquin qui est trop
chère maman prix vert à la fnac ça le
papillon des toiles de bernard werber
gratuit ce serait déjà trop cher pour ma
bourse et il en vend pourtant il en vend
des millions c'est pas ça s'achète mais
ça se vend le bouquin qui ne l'était pas
de trouver un éditeur
les bienveillantes jeunes à tallinn le
bouquin avec le meilleur maigres les
bienveillantes de jonathan littell son
ex et richard millet oui c'est sur des
on dit que son père l'a écrit
qu'ils sont écrits comme une suite
lyrique et comme par hasard le
bienveillante ya un passage ils dominent
des charniers il parle de de blanchot de
maurice blanchot tu passes au milieu des
house vite su parles tu diras maurice
blanchot d'un grand écrivain ça c'est
une obsession de milliers par exemple le
bouquin qui sert à rien alors les
bouquins ne servent pas à quelque chose
dans la littérature ne sert jamais à
rien sauf les mauvais livres comme les
bienveillantes de jonathan littell qui
sert à poser question sur le show à mes
bouquins on l'avait attendu pour ça le
bouquin qui nous a réconciliés avec les
prix littéraires comme j'ai toujours
considéré que les prix littéraires ne
servent à rien les bienveillants de john
hamilton le bouquin qui vous a donné
envie de tuer panthéon dianne watts
parce que les critiques dégueulasse que
j'ai mon honneur fin je vais c'est
marrant d'ailleurs maintenant vous êtes
carrément écrivain maudit quoi c'est
bien ouais ben position comme ça je fais
des films très populaires comme podium
et puis ça me permet écrire des livres
maudits y arrive sur les deux tableaux
il ya un mec dans libé qui aviez dit il
y en a marre des mecs qu'on déteste
c'est comme pas la faute
le bouquin vous auriez aimé écrire cette
année les bienveillantes jade nba
puisqu'il goncourt quand
[Rires]
[Musique]
voilà et maintenant comme c'est devenu
une tradition dans cette émission on
passe en revue le reste de l'actu avec
sa main tu es res où je m'en bats les
couilles
il fait super froid cette semaine ça
vous intéresse vous embêter des coûts
alors là je suis contente parce que j'ai
acheté plein de trucs faut que les met
les pulls et manteaux tout ça eric vous
embêter les couilles du temps oui oui
qui trompe pas les choses j'ai su qu'il
faisait froid parce que j'ai vu zidane
allant chez nadia avec un bonnet
les fonctionnaires sont augmentés de 4
euros ça m'intéresse je m'en bats les
couilles ça m'intéresse c'est sûrement
oui pas plus quoi ouais ouais vous voyez
bien ça va non pas mal oui oui oui 6500
euros comme albi dans en plus fréquentes
et tapis johnny ville et bernadette
chirac s'intéresse à vous et cg c'est
d'arriver à leur niveau ouais ouais
tienne m'a mis en prison ça vous
intéresse dans la téléco et
j'aimerais bien que ça m'intéresse mais
je crois que finalement je m'en bats les
couilles sauf pour la victime et le
bourreau m'intéresse pas
c'est inadmissible
voilà faudel soutient sarkozy ça vous
intéresse vous battez les couilles
[Musique]
on pressent que c'est un intérêt
[Rires]
a conclu me suis blessé par une bombe
agricole lancé par un supporter de l'om
ça vous intéresse oui ça m'intéresse
ouais
ça m'intéresse pour le la désignation de
l'auteur de de cet envoi imbéciles comme
bouc émissaire comme un souvent j'allais
faire je reste persuadé qu'il est lui
aussi victime d'une ambiance victimes de
l'argent victimes de finalement oui bon
je l' ai vu ce garçon j'ai un avantage
sur d'autres je n'ai vu un pauvre garçon
je regrette qu'on ait envoyé en prison
même à titre provisoire parce que je
prends pas que ce soit sa place j'espère
simplement qu'il en sortira pas pire
qu'il n'y est entré j'espère qu'il sera
pas violer j'espère qu'il ne subira pas
de brimades voilà c'est ce qui me gêne
dans cette affaire ce qui me gêne c'est
les hypocrites autour qui viennent
saluer le sapeur pompier sur son lit
avec des larmes de crocodile en oubliant
leurs propres responsabilités on lave de
bertrand laroche qui porte plainte
contre france 3 suite au téléfilm sera
fermée demain bien sûr que ça
m'intéresse parce que je crois qu'on est
en train de tourner actuellement un
téléfilm sur l'affairé allègre j'ai vu
ça hier à bordeaux je comprends pas très
bien je crois qu'il vaut mieux connaître
vraiment la fin de l'histoire avant d'en
faire un film tout ça logique on a tout
ça devient insupportable vous avez
raison c'est assez logique ce la route
du rhum cela vous intéresse vous embêter
les couilles j'adore moi c'est que c'est
lui les terriens donc les
extraterrestres quark sur la planète
terre et des êtres humains qu'ils soient
s'intéresse à tous soit se battre nico
ses traits et manichéen et je m'en bats
les couilles
et leur homme tout court
j'adore j'ai
bien sûr mais ça vous intéresse jean
françois copé qui a bidonné une
rencontre avec la presse dans un café
pour la promotion de la baisse de la
taxe sur les flippers ça vous intéresse
la seule chose qui m'intéresse si on
veut s'occuper si sa femme ah oui elle
très déçu mais je suis d'accord elle est
sublime tout à fait bander d'accord dit
paul maccartney accusé d'avoir battu sa
femme ça vous intéresse vous embêter les
covial c'est pas possible c'est pas
croyable ses fastes avec michel madame
c'est un peu ce mec qui m'a écrit une
telle
jeunesse quant à la carte mais c'est ma
cousine
muriel robin qui attaquent paris match
en justice pour avoir publié une photo
d'elle avec son amie anne ça vous
intéresse
fortement que ça pourrait nous arriver
quoi quinn intéresse pas muriel robin
le fils de jean luc delarue s'appelle
jean ça vous intéresse et riku vous
embêter les flots il aimait qu'une
oreillette le mot
ce qu'il fait ou vous trouvé vos
questions l'om prend 10 but en trois
matches ça vous intéresse vous embête
hélico et alors ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de savoir à quel point jean becker
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
merci lannoy
[Applaudissements]
je me refuse à
faire sur canal
d'ici là place
[Musique]
sans blague
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux